Sometimes science is hands on.
Really hands on.
Hey everyone, Julian here for DNews.
Rule 35 is: if it exists, there is a scientist
studying it.
Rocks?
Got it.
Space?
You bet.
Rocks in space?
Oh yeah, someone is all over that.
But sometimes, in the quest to seek out knowledge
wherever it may be hiding, scientists have
to get their hands dirty.
And sticky.
Sometimes they have to spank the monkey...literally.
It’s not just done for enjoyment, although
I’m sure the monkey doesn’t mind.
How orgasms fit into our evolution is still
a bit of a question mark.
What purpose do they serve?
Males orgasms are usually tied to a release
of sperm, so if ejaculating feels good in
the short term then it’s more likely to
breed more offspring long term.
That makes sense.
But females can have offspring with or without
a climax, so why do they happen?
Explanations vary.
Maybe the sensation is enjoyable enough that
seeking it out is worth the risk of copulating,
which leaves you a bit exposed to predators
in the wild.
Or since humans start out developing the same
in the womb, the same structure that becomes
the penis in men is the clitoris in women,
so maybe it’s just vestigial.
If that’s the case, is it only other primates
that have male and female orgasms?
Did it start with mammals 65 million years
ago or are there other animals that can experience
it too?
These are the questions scientists aim to
answer with their hands on experiments.
Like in a 1981 Institute of Primate Studies
study where psychologist William Lemmon had
his grad student bring female chimps to orgasm
by hand.
Or at least what they think was an orgasm,
based on the muscle contractions and facial
expressions.
Of course they couldn’t ask the chimp directly
if it orgasmed, so it is possible it faked
it so it wouldn’t hurt his feelings.
Either way I think we can all agree no one
has done more to earn a master's degree than
those students.
They even reported one chimp climaxed on ten
separate occasions, which, ok, now you’re
just showing off.
But even though it may sound silly, these
experiments demonstrated that yes, other female
primates can orgasm too, and the female orgasm
might be an evolutionary advantage we picked
up from a distant relative.
Other times scientists *ahem* stimulate animals
because they just want to know what’s up
with animal sex.
Like Patricia Brennan of Yale University who
wanted to know how ducks get down.
Most birds mate by pressing rear ends together
and exchanging fluids.
Not ducks.
Ducks have crazy corkscrew penises that they
shoot out of their body.
Female ducks have vaginas that can corkscrew
in the opposite direction.
To see how that affected mating, Brennan waited
until a male was just about to mount a female,
then quack jacked them, swapping the female
for one of 4 oddly shaped tubes.
She found that certain shapes were much harder
for males to enter.
She noted that a female that actually wants
to mate with a male can relax and position
itself to be more receptive, but otherwise
she can make it more difficult to copulate,
avoiding unwanted fertilization.
Ducks are among the 3% of bird species that
have penises, and one species, the red-billed
buffalo weaver, actually has a false penis
that serves no reproductive purpose.
It has no sperm duct and doesn’t become
erect.
Yet females seem to prefer males with larger
fake phalluses.
And when it’s stimulated the males do seem
to achieve orgasm.
How do scientists know this?
Because they did it themselves.
Why it works?
They don’t know.
More research is needed.
Science isn’t all microscopes and behavior
observations.
Sometimes to further scientific studies we
have to look closely at what we may see as
taboo.
But remember, sex, orgasms and semen are part
of life.
And understanding them will help us understand
us.
Scientists aren’t just interested in the
orgasms, they also study sperm.
And they’ve found some little swimmers that
went freestyle.
Laci and Alex break it down here.
Will it be you who boldly goes where no human
man has gone before?
Or would you rather not watch how they do
it on the Discovery Channel?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more and I’ll see you next time on DNews.